[Music]
welcome to your biscuits
the lifelong podcast where
the lifelong broadcast i mean that's
quite a commitment
i mean you want to do this until we die
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life
for their entire lives i'm link and i
read this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we are talking about
some of the habits of successful people
now i'm not talking about
like that book the seven seven habits of
successful people
we're talking about things that you may
or may not have ever thought about we're
kind of talking about the weird
secret habits of success yeah because
just the normal
habits of successful people that's
that's boring
i mean we want to go strange but i do
think that there's going to be some
takeaways from this
they may not be direct to what we're
talking about they may be
the opposite of what we're talking about
or maybe you do want to jump in
and into a pool and almost drown
yourself i don't know we'll have to find
out but
sometimes it's just helpful to take a
step back and evaluate
is there any new practice that i can
incorporate
into my life some some new healthful
habit that
might become the key to accomplishing
something you know like kind of over
promising of this like
oh i don't think anybody else might
listen to our podcast
so that they can become successful or do
they
they listen to i i can't feel like then
i listen to our podcast took escape
from thinking about success and things
like that this was your idea
yeah just only because i thought it
would be interesting to talk about
so you can do something like sw sweep up
your child's
art project that they just dropped on
the ground and that's what people that's
not a habit
no people i'm saying people listen to
ear biscuits while doing other things
and so for the person who's sweeping up
your child's art project that you
accidentally
uh broke first of all don't tell them
they're going to forget about it did
this happen to you today
no uh maybe you'll want to become more
successful
from listening to this but that's not
the intention the intention is to have
an interesting conversation but listen
maybe we'll discover something that is
the exact opposite maybe
you you need a practice to help you
accomplish less
and enjoy life more i yeah i'm promising
big on this man
okay well then you better not you better
deliver i'm not backing down
at all uh today we're gonna look at
habits of successful people
that are strange and
may or may not have contributed to their
success or their well-being or their
their genius or their um
their fame but maybe there's something
in it for us i
i'm just saying let's approach it with
an open mind oh i approach
all things with an open mind maybe
there's something that my middle name is
open mind can
revolutionize well that would be two
names revolutionize
our experience you know i
well and i gotta say i gotta go ahead
and say preemptively that
um at least three of these are things
that
i was already zeroing in on but i think
maybe this is gonna take me to the next
level again
i'm not saying it so that you'll do it i
picked all of these because they sounded
crazy
not knowing that you did any of them
well i'm doing three so
that kind of adds up for what i don't
know exactly why you're listening
i think right and i have different ideas
today what will keep you listening but
as long as you keep listening
and as long as you buy stuff from our
sponsors just kidding not kidding but
um we're happy just hang out
we're going to get to that in a second
though but you know what something
pretty monumental is happening
um there was we have a we have a
four-way group text with the two of us
and our wives
and in that group text uh this morning
i think well i think maybe it was a text
from your wife to my wife who was like
hey you know today
is our 10-year anniversary of being in
los angeles and i was like
no it's not it's it's it's not that
it's not today it's two days from now
and i was like
so you knew the actual date well the
reason why she said that is because
something
something popped up on her you know it
was either facebook or one of those
google photos or something where it's
like 10 years ago today
this was happening well the here's how i
know because
and she was she ended up being two days
early me and you
of course drove across the entire
country we got to los
angeles one day before our wives and
children showed up on a plane
and i have a picture that i took from
the balcony of the apartment that we
rented
yeah and there's a date on that uh
march 11th 2011
and then jesse was like well
did we come the next day and then she
brings up her phone
and she finds the video that she took in
the
rdu airport when they were all getting
ready to get on the plane and she goes
around with the phone and she asks all
five
kids all right guys tell me
what we're doing what do you guys think
where are we going and she starts with
lily
so this is ten years ago so lily was
seven
years old almost eight almost eight
and it was just it's so it's so crazy
like when i think about how long we've
been in los angeles oh i know i'm just
like it doesn't
feel like we've been here that long no
but then when you see our children i
watched the video and yeah i was
thinking the same thing i was like
when we moved here first of all
you know we were in a furnished
apartment so we didn't move everything
we kind of did this like staggered
approach to kind of ease into it
and that way when we left we could tell
our family and friends that
this might not be permanent just six
months our furniture's still in our
homes
of course we were thinking we're going
to make this happen we you know
in success we we're going to stay out
there
or not success
that was guess what you thought and i
was i was too scared to
think that um at that point but
yeah i really didn't think of it as like
we're doing that thing where you moved
to a new city it was like we're going
and we're doing this we're making this
show
and we just happen to have to be in this
city to do it and this is
this is it does feel like some dreams
coming true type of thing and that kind
of
so much going on that it wasn't just
about relocation well that's why the
kids didn't say
we're moving to california that's why
lily was like we're going to california
and okay now did you notice that
uh so it's so amazing how
indicative of their personalities all of
them are in this video so you got
lily lily what are we doing uh
how do you feel about it
who's like kind of like she's going to
answer the questions
she's going to engage she's going to be
like we're going so and so so
and then then they go to lincoln and
he's got this funny look on his face
and jesse's like how do you feel about
traveling today and he was like i don't
know what that means hey lincoln
oh here comes my mom tell me what your
thoughts are
on this move
i don't know what that means yeah
and then she goes to lock and lock is
standing up turned away from the camera
and you know why he's doing that because
he was first of all he's a challenger
but he was very upset about moving he
did not want to leave north carolina
and in fact in the first couple of weeks
that we were in los angeles
he said i would rather be a doorknob
that's like one of his famous quotes is
i would rather be a doorknob than be in
california i don't know how i thought
but did you and so do you notice in the
video where jesse's
he's facing away and then he says
something like
we're gonna go and uh jesse's like we're
going to go see your dad in california
and he says something like i'm going to
insult my dad i might insult you
no no no no no no we're going to be
respectful are you excited about this
trip
no actually i'm not
and why is that oh it's pretty normal
pretty normal okay or you see he said
something like that and then she turns
around
he turns around and he's just so upset
about it and of course
uh shepherd and i mean lando was like
fresh from the womb it seemed like lando
how do you feel about us moving to los
angeles
yeah can you show your tree let me see
your trick
man though you said so little
yeah he was one one that's fresh from
the womb in my book
that is very impressive
but but she panned a shepherd and he was
she would tell him what to say and then
he would say it shepherd
where are we going
to see my daddy okay and where is your
daddy what state is he in
california yes this is california
california he's super cute
is that all the kids do we that's it
that's all the kids yeah that's all the
ones we brought with us but
we don't talk about the ones we left in
north carolina they're currently being
raised by another family i mean their
their lives are defined by here
you know their whole experience how does
it make you feel has been defined by i
feel good about it well
the answer to that question is i don't
know what that means
i don't know what do you what do you
what do you want me to do like
develop thoughts and responses to
questions
yeah but ten years man ten year
anniversary in los
angeles like i said it just went by it
went by so fast
but i do i do think about it from the
perspective of the kids it's like
yeah we made this choice because of
what we were doing and what we wanted to
do and the
effect was our kids are from california
i mean that's how that's how
that's how they think about it and
they're they're doing just fine they're
doing great
yeah i think they are i mean they're
doing great they're doing great they're
doing great
no they are doing great it's just i when
i think about how they're doing right
now i still think about the fact that
they're not yet back in school
yeah they've got their channel i want
them to be back in school as soon as
possible
not because i'm tired of dealing with
them at home
online school i'm just saying they're
tired of online school
they're the ones who are tired of it 10
years man congratulations
let's celebrate let's celebrate by
reassessing our lives and seeing if
there's something else we can
incorporate into it some some new
practice that's going to change
everything or nothing
because that's not why you're listening
right uh but first let's uh
let's see if we can get people to buy
that hoodie you're wearing
okay let me give it a shot i'm wearing
this hoodie
uh it's uh it's got that tie-dye thing
going on
it's a it's a cool color
it says it has mythical logo right there
you want to rep your boys you want to be
warm this is a subtle promo
you want to put your hoodie on i get it
you're kind of trying to get them to
make a decision then
i'm making the decision for mythical.com
just
comes in it comes in this teal color and
it comes in a
a purple issue we call it we call it
crystal wash we had one that was like
gray and black and now we've got uh
these pastel colors
put the hood on hood hood goes all the
way over
the head you can wear it while in the
ears easter egg hunting or you can just
wear it
by just while hunting now i'm i'm
wearing this in order to promote it
and i might i don't know what we're
going to talk about i might sweat i'm
actually i'm actually sweating a little
bit i'm just going to tell you
but i might do it it might turn into one
of those stink sweats depending on what
we talk about where it's like
while we're really processing something
and that makes you
smell i i don't know it makes more stink
come out i feel like when you
really are having a stress sweat
and if that happens then this hoodie's
going to stink and then if you pick it
up off the rack and decide to put it on
it might stink like that last hoodie
that uh
we were we were modeling for
mythical.com and it stunk so
i'm not going to throw anybody that
wasn't me oh i know
it was an extra large i wouldn't have
put that on it wasn't actually large it
was a large
oh maybe it was me here no it wasn't you
yeah you know what my stink smells like
i don't unless you forgot to wear a
deodorant for a
full day and wore that with no
undershirts this is a long ad
i think we should start just doing a a
podcast that's just an ad
we could talk for just an ad it's a
whole new it's a whole new podcast it's
a sidebar
would anybody listen to that yeah if it
was good enough rhett
link add cast
it's it's just and but it's not ad reads
it's just where it works
we're talking about it yeah we're
talking about stuff because i know you
don't want to
listen to us read more ads as a whole
podcast but promoting stuff
i think that malcolm gladwell uh podcast
that we had as a sponsor
was just an ad you know the one that was
sponsored by lexus
yeah but it wasn't it wasn't we weren't
selling something the entire time
directly
no i'm saying that podcast was it was a
uh wasn't just an ad
oh not a selling oh yeah a podcast it
was a brand of their podcast that was
just an ad we did an ad for a podcast
that was just an ads
yeah but i mean malcolm gladwell it was
interesting
anyway rep your boys mythical.com
all right um let's just get started with
ben franklin
why not let's go there take a naked
air bath is something you might want to
consider doing
on a daily basis because ben franklin
did that
he would sit naked in the cold air for a
half hour to an hour
each morning because he believed that
cold water
was too much of a shock to the system
well the way you put because in there is
misleading
as opposed to doing that he believed
that being in the cold was going to be
helpful but he thought that the air
would be better than
the alternative which would be cold
water i've talked about what i said i've
talked about it before
on this podcast i told you that i was
assembling the different
parts to make my own ice bath so the
yeah so the ice bath
thing especially since wim hof
the iceman kind of made this concept
popular
it's something that's in the the the
popular culture it's in the vernacular
now
where people are doing the athletes
taking ice baths whatever
and so there's all these there's all
this research that suggests that first
of all
saunas have all these health benefits so
i'll go let me go to the hot side first
right
i'll go with you to the hot side now all
kinds of
evidence just piling up that people who
spend
like four to seven days in at four to
seven times a week
and they and they studied all these guys
and you know it's very popular in the
culture of the men
in the like uh you know sweden norway
scandinavian
dudes very big for them to take
to you know to go into saunas all the
time a lot of times like public saunas
and they follow there's multiple studies
but one of the most famous studies shows
that people and again this is kind of a
cultural thing so
you know more men were doing it so men
are the ones that have been studied but
it this probably affects everybody in a
positive way if you
take a sauna if you take a sauna bath
of like 20 minutes or so at 175 degrees
four to seven times a week it has all
these
incredible health effects like basically
reduces your all-cause mortality that's
like
in dying of anything by a
large percentage now you can go look up
the study to get the specifics
i don't i'm not i don't have it in front
of me so i'm not going to give you the
specifics but it's also
shown to have effects on like mood
and you know all kinds of things makes
it makes you feel good
so because of that when we we redid
i've always loved being hot in general
but
when we redid the uh outdoor area i got
a sauna installed because i was like i'm
gonna do this
and i'm basically doing it every night
every night
if i'm at home i'm doing it definitely
six times out of uh
six times 20 minutes so
i first of all go for i have a a like a
manual i have a timer that's an
hourglass for 15 minutes and what i do
is i go 15 minutes and i get out and
i'll talk about that because i'm coming
back to ben franklin
cool off and then i go back in for
another 15 minutes so it ends up being
about a half hour
and currently i'm
oscillating between 195 and 205 degrees
is where i've gotten to
your tolerance builds up pretty fast so
it's when i first got the thing it was
like 140 i was like it's hot in here
and then over the course of a few months
i'm already over 200 degrees so
you can do it and it can and you begin
to crave it
but what i do is i go into the sauna
then i get out of the sauna and i get
into the pool
which like last night it was 46 degrees
out
okay so it might be 55 degrees low
50s i think was 52 degrees in the pool
get in the pool
and i hang in the pool for about five
minutes good gosh
that's hard to do the first time yeah
you
begin to crave it like when we watched
that
octopus his teacher he talked about how
he began to crave the cold i was like
this dude's nuts he said it took him a
year but that
was way colder he was way colder than i
am
and then i get out and you get back into
the sauna and you get back into the
sauna and it's like 205 degrees and it
takes you about five minutes to realize
that it's hot because you were just so
cold
and then i go for 15 minutes and then i
get out and i get back in the pool and
then
ben franklin coming back to ben franklin
i get out of the pool
and i stand outside
for at least 10 minutes last night in it
i was in i was wet
out of the pool in a wet bathing suits
46 degrees but it's colder outside of
the pool than
in the pool but that's something about
coming out of the cold water because of
the heat transfer
the water feels colder so i came out and
i just stood next to the pool and was
like continuing to listen
listen to the podcast that i had going
and i just stood there for 10 minutes
before i began to feel uncomfortable
it's it's revolution have you noticed
how i haven't been wearing a jacket
like it'll be cold in our office and
like me and you used to be like man it's
cold in here we put on a layer we put on
another jacket
yeah i've been thinking i'm hot like i
don't i haven't worn a jacket
i haven't worn a jacket except maybe one
time
when i went when we went over to your
house to hang out in the backyard the
other night i wore a jacket i was like
this is the first time i've worn a
jacket in a while
because my body has adjusted do you
notice any other
changes i mean i feel good but i don't
know if that has anything to do with it
you're not
dead i didn't die of any cause i feel
good
i haven't like tested it's supposed to
like lower your blood pressure which i
kind of had like borderline
blood pressure but i haven't tested that
in a couple months i probably should
test that well
you know i'd be interested to try that i
highly recommend this
well i'm not coming over to your house
every day to get in your persona
you should get you should get one of
those infrared saunas man you can i
would have to try it before i
yeah i go all in but being really cold
is something that i don't like that's
why
i'm liking this ben franklin thing
because it's not a cold
shower or a cold pool plunge
it's just cold air he's like you know
what
i'm gonna do something he's so he's
sitting outside for just
naked naked in the cold for an hour
every morning
well and there are two things he was
onto something i mean science has proven
him
correct and said you need to go further
ben yeah i wonder if he understood what
was happening if he just had a sense for
it because
the the science of this is that what's
happening
with when so there's this stuff called
brown fat right
which is like it's fat that i guess
under a microscope looks darker
it's kind of scary gravy it's got uh
miter more mitochondrial
elements to it or something and this
isn't like
you can't see this fat it isn't like oh
i've got a lot of brown fat and you can
see that i'm overweight or whatever no
this is like fat that kind of
concentrates in your neck and your
shoulders and if you go back
to like pre-climate controlled times
so we're talking like thousands of years
ago everybody had way more brown fat and
they were able to regulate their
temperature and be
cold and not really have a big deal with
it but now
we've lost all our brown fat because
we've got hoodies and jackets and
climate control and so
you don't need it and so you quickly
lose it but there's all these studies
that show
in fact there was one study i was
looking at there was these guys who
they slept i think uncovered
out out of a blanket in at 68 degrees
so like 68 degrees without a blanket
you'd be like this is a little
uncomfortable a little too cold right
just a little bit too cold yeah and then
and these men
did this for like six weeks and they all
had some
very noticeable increase in the amount
of brown fat
and what that ends up doing is you
become way more tolerant of cold
very quickly and then the moment they
went back to sleeping regular like
within a few weeks they lost the brown
fat
so you got to keep doing it but ben
franklin
had a bunch of brown fat because he was
doing this i'm telling you
and you know i mean he was way ahead of
his time brown fat franklin
yeah that's his nickname brown fat ben
franklin bf
telling you man it's a light just come
over to my house get in there
my wife got in there for like the first
time last night as a matter of fact
because she was like i just don't want
to get in there i feel like i'm going to
faint or whatever
i was like let's just do 175. put her on
175 she was there for 15 minutes
sweating like crazy it's kind of sexy
and then she came out and she was like i
feel good i was like all right we'll do
it again tomorrow night
i'm gonna live forever i'm not
but well one of us is gonna live longer
than the other and they're gonna have to
keep doing this podcast
yeah she's committed to doing it for our
entire lives all right this is one that
come came to mind immediately when we
started tossing around this topic
and it's it's one that we keep coming
back to because we're fascinated about
it
wear the same outfit every single day
of course steve jobs the most famous
example of this
uh wore the same black well i don't
think it was the same black turtleneck
he wore the same outfit but it was
probably
different he probably had a closet full
of black turtlenecks blue jeans and new
balance sneakers
okay very particular of course it became
his signature look and a part of like
the apple aesthetic
and his rationale when asked about it
was that he had a finite capacity
of brain power to make well thought out
decisions
and he wanted to minimize his decision
fatigue a minute more a day using his
brain power to decide which t-shirt to
wear
is less brain power he would have to
think about his company
um many people have fallen into this uh
because this has been out you know
everybody's known this for the past 20
years or so
obama did it um you know he only wore
gray or black suits except for that one
time that he wore the brown suit and
everybody wanted to suit
the tansy wanted to talk about it and
yeah he told vanity fair that he wants
he's trying to pare down decisions he
said i don't want to make decisions
about what i'm eating
or wearing because i have too many other
decisions to make and just as a side
note i totally
relate to that we've asked jenna just to
if if the crew is ordering food for us
just get whatever we've got before
whatever you know will like because
stopping and making stopping and making
the decision about what in the middle of
making a bunch of decisions
so i do think this is demoralizing maybe
this is like uh
if you're if your job is defined
by making constant decisions
would lead you to consider something
like this
yeah and the whole idea of a
of a president i mean first of all the
president is going to wear a suit every
day
so that feels like if you've got uh if
you have a club
after the pandemic man he's going to be
wearing sweats just like everybody else
what i'm saying i'm going to be wearing
them sweats like all the
uh the college basketball coaches like
we talked about
they ain't going back to suits either
right but the idea
the the president that i doesn't really
track for me because
they're already just they're just
wearing a suit like it's not like
it's like yeah i have a closet full of
suits
and just put it on uh all the late night
show hosts i mean they just they're just
giving a suit to wear
i mean they'll if they don't like it i'm
sure they won't wear it
but they're not going through and
picking it out every day well you have
to wear one every day
but this but so but i'm surprised that
there's it's not someone's job
to pick out the president's suit every
day i had to believe it was but the way
that
obama talked about it it seemed like
he wanted to simplify it well because
because i guess
if you're wearing like oh this is a tan
suit oh you got me in this thing now
then even though you're not making the
decision what to wear you you have
veto power over it and you're still
assessing it
you're giving attention to it so it does
make sense to me
i guess that a president would be
tempted to
to allocate mental resources to that
okay but you like the idea of pulling
steve jobs i've been
okay i do not i've been trying to land
this
for myself for the past couple months
okay and i
now when i say land this i don't mean
get
as specific as same exact
shirt he had multiple black turtlenecks
but they were all black turtlenecks and
all
blue jeans are the same color new ballot
sneakers that look the same
but i have been thinking about um
creating like a couple of options
like if it is between
x and y degrees in a certain day
then i know what i'm going to wear is
these jeans this shirt
and maybe just a couple of choices of
shoes right
and then if it's a little bit warmer
okay i'm gonna wear this t-shirt so
wow now for me it has
less to do with decision fatigue the
lunch decision
is very much about decision fatigue
because me and you will be
in a conversation about something we're
making decisions our
our job has largely become making
decisions right
we've gotten a little bit better at kind
of making it where we're actually
doing creative things but and we're
managing a lot of things so
but for when jenna comes into jenna
comes in and does that it throws us off
but
in the morning it's kind of like all
right it's not
it's almost like a buffet like i've got
all the clothes there but for me
my it's my body type it's my height and
so it's very difficult
90 of the clothes that i own once you
wash them once i have to be really
careful about how i wash them because
shirts get too short or shirts get you
know shirts that are
long enough or too big shirts that are
the right
are tight enough or too short pants you
can it's just being an unusual body type
and so i've been on a hunt for just a
t-shirt
that i can reliably wear every single
day
now you see i wear the t-shirts that we
sell in the mythical store all the time
right
here's the issue with with those shirts
an extra large is a little bit bigger
than a shirt that i want to wear
and a large looks perfect until you
until i wash it and our shirts don't
even shrink that much but i'm dealing
with such a small margin of error here
tall man problems
and so like i've tried multiple like
tall fitting t-shirts and this is like i
can't quite
because again i just want to have like a
closet not the same color just like okay
there's 10 different colors of t-shirts
just blank t-shirts with nothing else to
me it's not about yeah so it's not about
this
it's about fit it's about you know
having something but it is
it's about the time because when you
have an issue with things
fitting you know what's gonna happen is
you go in your closet and you know
you're going to put something on and
there's a
75 chance you're going to put it on and
be like i'm not really comfortable in
this because it's not
fitting in this way so you've added time
to your day and so it is about time for
me
and so i've got these and then if you
run out of time then you might
you you lack confidence see that's the
thing
like because you know i'm not trying to
rub your nose in this but for me going
into my closet is like
all right i'm getting dressed for the
day this is my
opportunity to express myself and to
embody what i'm anticipating or what i'm
feeling or the mode i'm going into
and if i have some new clothes then
there's
also something to get excited about oh i
can't wait to get out of my pajamas
today it's like you sometimes
you need that motivation so for me it's
like the self-expression excitement
variety of it but um
there are times when i'll put something
on and i'll go in front of the mirror
and i just won't be happy and i'll i'll
start over
or i realize that that doesn't match or
whatever and then
and then i do get frustrated and if that
happened to me every day
or multiple times a week i could i could
start going the way of uh
jobs well i think that it coincides with
there's two things that there's two
sort of prevailing things that are
happening that have led to this decision
the first is that the body shape thing
that i've just dealt with
my entire life just not being a normal
size
but then the second thing is the age
that i'm at right you know okay 43
even though i said i was 42 in that
sketch we did on instagram because i
forgot how old i was
uh i'm 43 and
you know this latest iteration of like
things going back to the to the 90s and
we talked about this i think maybe on an
episode where
the i quit caring so much about the
trends when i started realizing that i
was dressing like my children
so it's like okay oh now i've got this
like man
in my house this teenage man basically
you know and my son locke
and if like we're wearing the same
clothes it's like something just feels
off and
and then i'm like i just kind of don't
want to keep trying that
like i might like there comes a time i
think
in most people's lives where you just
say okay i'm
checking out of remaining with the
trends now
if we had stayed in north carolina and
worked as engineers we would have
checked out at like 24.
you know what i'm saying and then you
like kind of just keep dressing the same
way for the rest of your life and
the 25 year old engineer and the 55 year
old engineer could trade clothes and
nobody would know
right that's a phenomenon that happens
in a lot of workplaces
yeah but because hey we moved to los
angeles and oh and we're also on the
internet and we're trying to like
be relevant and cool you end up kind of
wearing things that represent like oh
this these guys understand fashion and
what's in style
and i just think my appetite for being
on that
edge is just waned over the past like
since i hit 40 really
and so now i'm just like i'm not saying
i want to look
like i don't i'm out of touch i'm just
saying find something that fits your
body
that you feel comfortable in that makes
it look i mean it looks cool
whatever it doesn't but you don't look
doesn't look like you're trying to be
cool just
looks like you are cool ten of them and
wear it every single day
hey so i'm i'm zeroing in on that i
haven't figured it out yet
especially if i mean if it's about fit
and then there's there's a number you
can get a couple of different colors
like i can i can feel that
all right i i i've been waiting to talk
about this one all right something else
that we could consider doing
to improve our lives is uh to drown
yourself
almost could lead to lots of success at
least
if you're an inventor prolific inventor
dr
yoshiro nakamatsu uh he patented the
floppy disk in 1952 but
i didn't have to tell you that uh he's
also patented over
3 300 inventions in his 74 years
on this planet and here's what he would
do
according to his own accounts many of
his
ideas hit him while he was close to
drowning now you might think
well he just needs to be more careful
around bodies of water
or you know he's like why does this do
drowning so much but he would do it
intentionally to quote starve the brain
of oxygen
you must dive deep and allow the water
pressure to deprive the
brain of blood 0.5 seconds before death
how do you time that
i visualize an invention
so he may be
dramatizing this thing it says then he
jots his idea down on an
underwater notepad yes and sweet
surface he's almost dying he has the
idea he doesn't come
up gasp for air and say oh my god i
almost died but
i've got this invention give me a sheet
of paper no he does that while he's
still
dying let me just i mean listen i don't
know underwater i don't want to be the
skeptic here but
if you almost die okay just i'm just
gonna do some math here
if you're half a second 0.5 if you're
literally half a second from death
and then you're still underwater how do
you then write it down doesn't the death
part come
it doesn't something about this doesn't
add up but i mean he's in 3 300
inventions adds up
yeah i mean this the notepad part had to
be made up
this is i don't know where you got i see
you got the source linked there
that's right because i knew that you
would be like this i'm just saying this
that that last part reeks of like
internet
creative you know liberties well right
it comes from the website tal
group inc dot wordpress.com
2015 06 eleven and it's got martha
stewart
on the website okay i'll take it all
back it must be true
yeah no but the i okay but the idea of
al group.net cultivating growth
but the idea of almost dying
i mean i i didn't there is that him
right is that him writing on his
underwear notebook there's a picture of
him right there
i see he's writing everything other than
the 0.5 seconds from death maybe that
was just a tidbit that he threw
maybe that's just what he feels don't do
this by the way oh yeah
please we'd have to tell you that right
i mean okay so this i mean this
underwater notepad man i haven't tried
this
but there is something to the whole idea
that
in fact i started watching there's a uh
there's a netflix show that
i didn't really commit to it but i
watched like an episode where
it's sort of the it's the whole the
moment of death and all the
research and ideas that come that moment
of almost dying and
the release of dmt into the brain and
all this stuff and the
experiences that people have i i don't
know what the world view
of this particular show is but they
spend a lot of time
like talking to there's like a research
institute that basically just believes
that yes
there's your soul survives there's
definitely life after death
and they have all these they have like a
compendium of all these testimonies of
people who've experienced these things
flatliners yeah but it made me think
about the movie flatliners for certain
but
it isn't people getting ideas but this
made me this made me think
i've heard einstein did this thing where
he would um he said that he came up with
a lot of his sort of breakthrough
ideas in the liminal space between
sleeping between being awake and and
being asleep
and that moment i get what i don't
there's a there's a technical term for
it's like hypnogagia or hitting a goat
you know
it's you know the hypnagogic jerk i'm
probably
saying the word wrong but it's that i'm
falling asleep and then you catch
yourself and people are like it's
because we used to be in trees they
don't really know exactly what happens
but
if you have an underwater notepad and
when you do that jerk you'll write down
it like an equation right but here's
your keith richards like uh
the rift to start me up right yeah so he
did the same thing
so because einstein's satisfaction
would had this happen to him so often
that he started doing this thing where
he would
sit in a chair and
he i can't remember he had like a pencil
that he held
above a plate basically he had this
built-in alarm so that he would start to
fall asleep and then when he did fall
asleep he would immediately wake himself
up
it sounds kind of like it would drive
you crazy but he did this multiple times
during the day
for two reasons number one he said that
these
mini naps like falling asleep and then
waking up immediately
happening over and over again in the day
was something that he needed he also
slept like 10 hours a night
so einstein got a lot of sleep uh
but it was also because in that moment
of almost falling asleep he was getting
these insights that he would then
write down i mean i haven't tried this i
mean
i'm interested in it if you're you know
if you're doing something so
heady as like trying to solve equations
or
have some sort of breakthrough with a
problem
or yeah it does apply to songwriting you
know
if if your entire existence
is really bent towards solving a problem
or
creating something in a very focused way
i you know we do so many different
things
um but we do have problems we're trying
to solve
and some things that are kind of like
nagging and kind of
give me anxiety and i wonder if there's
a way to
you know take a dive in my pool and
think about it
or as i'm falling asleep you know
do something that's going to wake me up
and just have an intention
of trying to solve these things well you
know it's interesting solve the problem
now that
we're talking about this i do it has hit
me
that while in the sauna
at these really high temperatures i'll
be listening i usually put on a podcast
or a book or something like that
and i feel like i'm having some
higher level of insight into something
and i'll come up with an idea and i'll
get out and i'll
i need to i need a like a sweatproof
notebook
because i mean like going out because i
can't bring my phone in there because
it's too hot
sweatproof and then i like wipe my hands
off and type something
you need a yoshiro nakamatsu he's
probably probably that one would
probably work the underwater pad would
also work as a
as a sweatpad but i thought there's
another book i was reading i can't
remember what it was but the guy
was talking about how there's a bunch of
thinkers in history who have
insisted that walking
is how you come up with ideas that
you've got to be in motion
in order like a bunch of people it was
like he quotes all these people
like i've never thought about this i
mean i've had ideas while walking and
sometimes you're like
let me take a walk on this well i don't
know the science behind it
but the idea that you're in motion
you kind of get your body and your mind
kind of doing something and then
something cracks open well i mean my
theory is
yeah i like to do a lot of thinking when
i'm
like riding my mountain bike i've
started doing that more often just kind
of taking
found this one trail i can do and in
in less than an hour and i know the
trail and i know it increasingly
better so i can devote more of my active
attention
to just not die not
not to dying or falling off the cliff or
you know where my
where my tire is but on other things
but the way that i think about those
things is
it's a little bit different than i would
think about them
if i was just sitting down at my desk
trying to solve the problem or trying to
to work something out you know it's it
it ruminates and i think
you know when you're in your body i do
think
that you think differently oh yeah and
so you can approach problems differently
or you and or a creative exercise
differently
so but because for me a lot of times i
i've noticed um you know you get so much
in your head about well i need to
accomplish this or i got to solve this
problem or i really want to create this
thing
right now and then it's it's kind of
self-defeating
when you're when you're just 100
focused on it there's a because then you
have all this self-awareness of like
the pressure you put on yourself but if
you're doing something else
or it kind of it kind of relieves that
pressure at least for me
to say you know i don't have to solve
this right now
so i can i can kind of play with the
idea
it's the difference between working with
an idea and playing with an idea
and so i don't i don't know any of the
science really behind it
but i've observed
that
the best solutions or ideas come from
left field when you
when you least expect it or when you
give room and remove the pressure
of having to show improve i kind of
experience it as a balance between
like if i sit down and i'm like okay i
need to
write this thing yeah and uh
like okay this you know i need to write
20 pages i like i and you kind of have
to there is sort of a
work sort of focus that happens
and i tend to be like all right i you
know there's certain problems that i'm
going to come to in this process
there are certain holes and there's
certain unanswered questions
but when i come to those unanswered
questions i'm not going to spend
a lot of time just sitting there
thinking about the solution i'm going to
arrive at a solution
put it as a placeholder maybe it ends up
being the final decision
and then i'm going to keep moving and
that way i'll be able to say hey for the
you sat down for two hours and you wrote
this much
but then what i'll find is if i if i've
done that if i've laid the track
and that track has some problems in it
right
then when i'm doing something completely
unrelated like sitting in the sauna
thinking about something else listening
to something else all of a sudden
the solution to that problem that i i
created a hole
and then all of a sudden the solution to
the problem
pops in in those other spaces and then i
go back to
into that now i'm back into work mode
and i take that solution that came to me
in a different phase and sort of the
play phase
yeah so that i i mean i have never
really even thought about
that being i don't do that intentionally
just as you talk about it i realize
that's what i do
naturally is just to kind of be like all
right
i could sit here for the next 30 minutes
thinking about this one problem
but i i'm a little bit adhd so i'm going
to end up
getting on the internet or doing
something else but if i just be like no
just move past that get to the next
thing
the solution to that will come later
while you're doing something else like
walking riding the bike
in the sauna whatever as long as you
don't start breathing before you come up
for air
that's the key uh yeah i didn't say that
uh that is how yoshiro nakamatsu died
oh you drunk really yeah he drowned i
wonder what he was coming up with it
must have been so good he couldn't come
up
i'm lying about that no source link is a
source hold on
so you're saying he might still be alive
yeah
well okay um because you can black out
pretty easily
and you should you definitely shouldn't
do anything like that first of all just
don't do it but if you are going to try
to do like holding your breath
don't do it by yourself do it in the
presence of someone else who can pull
you out of the water
i got another one for you this is
especially for you
um pythagoras you know
with this theorem and all that stuff i
don't know from like
500 bc give or take greek mathematician
um he i i didn't know this about him but
he
he's credited with popularizing a
meatless lifestyle
dubbed the father of vegetarianism so
you know he was this
you know he was a mathematician but it
was there was so much philosophy
and politics and you know all of these
thinkers greek thinkers and philosophers
and mathematicians and astronomers
you know we're figuring all this stuff
out and thinking about all these things
but
a lot of it was very contentious as i'll
get to in a second
but even though he did not
eat meat he just ate veggies he hated
beans he hated legumes and he had you
know he had
followers he had people that he was
teaching and that were like
uh learning from him and and
i guess being allegiant to his to his
beliefs
he he even forbade them
uh from eating or touching beans
what's wrong with this guy uh we don't
know if
it was for health or religious reasons
uh
um but here's what happened
he did die he is no longer alive
pythagoras
i guess that and there's all these
different accounts of how he died
one of them which i'll call a legend is
that
there were these attackers who attacked
a house that he and some of his
followers were in
for i mean again for that political
contention and it got to the point where
they were killing people
and as he fled
his this house he was getting away but
then he encountered a bean field
and he refused to run through the bean
field and then so he was caught by the
attackers
and killed he got what he deserved and
this is ridiculous
so uh if you want to be a successful
mathematician you should avoid beans
i never liked the pythagorean theorem i
always questioned it
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared you i just i did hear the
question mark
as you said it i mean it's like really
yeah really really
yes yes i don't know yes i i honestly
don't know
it is a theorem um
this is strange this is a strange this
is a strange position
i understand that not eating meat okay
but most people who
don't eat meat it's weird that they who
sell the idea to me are like well you
can eat beans all the time
yeah mentality as a substitute could not
tell me why
he hated beans but there is this whole
uh health meets religion meets you know
all of these ideas are floating around
all these ideas are floating around yeah
i mean
i could see what about them i think that
was the field
oh um i uh
i got this um if you want to know how to
do triangle math
avoid the beans we don't need to talk
about anything we can move on well i
don't
i just wanted you to know right well no
but i i just i feel like i
i got this uh i'm not going gonna say
what brand it is because
i don't know what i think about them yet
but they've got a bunch of fake meat
and um again the principle of eating
less meat
i'm all on board i get it i understand
the impact on the
environment and so and also just the
impact on lifestyle so
the idea of minimizing meat intake is
something that i'm personally interested
in
the fact that i like beans makes that
somewhat easier the idea is something
you're personally interested in the
practice is a little bit more practice
is more difficult
because um because of the whole meat
part of it
yeah i'm with you man well here okay
i'll be honest with you
i'm kind of holding out for fake
meat like real fake meat like lab-grown
meat like meat that's actually meat but
that was grown in a lab yeah yeah
because
they're going to be able to do that with
so much less environmental impact and
obviously
it's going to be considerably more
humane because it won't require
slaughtering any animals
and by not becoming vegetarian or vegan
we both i can make it to that cross that
bridge well
we're actually creating an environment
where where that
where that can succeed we're making an
incentive
we're incentivizing them because you're
not going to get the world to just
decide to stop eating the whole world
might be able to get lab grown meat
right that's why that's why i keep
eating meat to demonstrate the demand
for meatless meat this is quite a theory
that's what i'm doing i'm doing
i i i'm i'm a long it's a long play for
the environment
okay well i appreciate that but i got
this meat that's made from beans
and this doesn't happen when i do like a
impossible burger or like beyond meat
i don't think it happens but i got this
are you gonna talk about poo poo
this meat that had been made with with
beans and other things
and they send you like a pack of it and
it's there's taco meat there's sausages
there's hamburgers all these different
fake meats
and you know i like to do the scramble
thing on the weekend i make a scramble
for my wife and i
that's not correct grammar by the way be
my wife and me
i'm losing you i'm losing you man but i
uh
i made this taco scramble with this fake
taco meat didn't work
in the whole weekend it was this past
past weekend saturday and
i came over to your house on saturday
night i didn't want to talk about it
you know but i was in like
bloat pain the whole time i was there
you were grimacing it was just like very
bloated very like
not and i know i guess maybe you would
adjust over time but i eat a fair amount
of beans it's just
it's like why is it the human body if
the human body is supposed to only eat
vegetables
then why is it so difficult
for me to digest the vegetables well
it's because because you wear hoodies
man
it's the same thing it's like the brown
fat's gonna go away you gotta you gotta
get
you're saying i've i've i've i'm
mal-adjusting you're soft
i'm mal-adjusted you're soft but what's
your
what's your point just i'm saying i want
to i want to
not make a full switch but i want to
minimize meat
i want to eat some of that the fake
meatless meat on there the lab grown
is the lab grown me is where as i know
it's gonna
it's gonna be difficult to convince
people because they're all scared of
things from the lab but
we'll get there we'll get there i want i
wanted to put one in here
that wasn't so strange but i just
thought was so
personally impactful speaking of
impactful that's a
sunday afternoon man one of the things
that all those beans came in one of the
things
one of the habits that you can
incorporate into your life that
i have incorporated it's made a
difference that's popped up on these
lists that we looked at
was me time or according to one ted
speaker
named stephen cutler he calls it
non-time
i did not watch the ted talk because i
read this sentence and that's all i
needed to know
he discusses the importance of down time
that is just for you
and here's the key it doesn't require
you to think about
anything at all uh einstein did this
steve jobs did this
dwayne the rock johnson wakes up early
for a quiet time now we woke up early
for quiet times or at least that's what
we but it meant something very specific
yeah that was like
a bible study in prayer time yeah it was
it was a christian spiritual exercise
now
um and we also weren't very good at it
not very consistent
now that sometimes
i have me time i aim to have me time
every morning i'm such a
you know i i have this sense of what i
ought to be doing
and i certainly have this sense of like
if i'm not
meeting my own expectations as a
perfectionist and
um so i always have this you know that
that voice in my head that's like should
i be doing something different should i
be doing
should i be doing better than this am i
meeting my standard you know
uh am i contributing
or am i being lazy or whatever the case
may be you know
so it's actually scheduling time where
the goal
and the task is to do nothing
have no obligations so you know
i set my alarm 30 minutes earlier and
then i'll go down i'll drink my coffee
and i'll just sit on the couch
now when i'm done with my coffee or done
with enough of my coffee that like
i'm ready to move on to the next thing
that's when i like actually
do a meditation so and i do consider
meditation as part of this me time
because i mean
the practice of mindfulness meditation
is to um to not think
to not think or to acknowledge the
thoughts that you're having but
but not to obligate yourself to engage
in those thoughts so it gives you
space it gives you headspace now
actually it's a headspace is going to be
a sponsor on good mythical morning it's
not a sponsor here but
i mean i've tried lots of different
meditation apps
and uh they're all good for different
reasons but headspace
is a great introductory one and i'm glad
that their sponsor um
again they're not a sponsor right now
but since i'm talking about it and if
you are interested
uh you can use our code ear you got it
it's headspace.com
ear and then you gotta put in the coupon
code ear
to get i can't remember what it is right
now it's a good deal it's a deal
um and it helps us in any way
uh i'm not great at it and we've talked
about it
in the past and how we've you know you
get into it you have seasons of being in
and out of it
but whether you're actually learning and
participating
practicing mindfulness meditation or if
you're just taking time to where it's
like you know what
i'm drinking my tea i'm drinking my
coffee i'm just gonna sit here
and i'm just going to notice myself
i'm going to notice what i feel like i'm
going to notice if i'm
you know am i experiencing anxiety or
what you know
whatever the case may be and just give
yourself freedom to just
not have to engage with the way that my
brain works
i i really do think it's making a huge
difference in my capacity to
then go on with my life for the rest of
the day
yeah it's really tough for me to do it
in the morning
um i think i've replaced it and i know
most of the time i am listening to
something
but like i'm getting that like half hour
every pretty much every day in the sauna
and i've thought about making that into
meditation but it's almost the heat it
is so intense that you need to just i
need something to kind of
focus on but it is a very meditative
time and when i get out of the
thing kind of in between them and pull
whatever but
i've been working out in the morning and
there was a time when i was meditating
and then working out
and it's just like i have to get up so
early in order
to because my workout's like an hour and
so
it's it's it's what's so tough but well
but that's what it is for me
are you saying because i was i did want
to just
flat out ask you know what is the
the one practice that you would point to
for you personally
that uh is the key to your
either success or personal well-being if
you were to nail it down to
to one thing i think i think for me it
is that
that that me time and then i think a
corollary is
beginning to see exercise as something
that
allows me to um to get out of my head
and get into my body
and so it's not just about all the other
things you associate with working out
but it's just about it gives my it gives
my brain a break
to actually engage in rigorous physical
activity
well so i think that's my answer well
i mean one thing before i give you my
answer
is you know um
eckhart tolle talks about how
mindfulness is kind of a misnomer
that it's not it's actually a
mistranslation because
his whole deal is about how the mind is
the problem
you know what i'm saying like thoughts
and your mind feeling like it has to be
active and it has to be doing something
and identifying yourself with your mind
is like the key to all suffering
essentially he
does a much better way of talking about
it he's also his voice is very
intoxicating
but so mindfulness is actually
about not thinking like yeah you the
reason that you
focus on your breath or you observe a
thought
is actually so you won't think about
those things and you won't you won't go
down a rabbit trail and that's why you
keep bringing your
thoughts back to your your breath so you
don't
think and i and
so i mean i find meditation to be very
helpful in
that even though it's
so difficult for me to stop thinking
because even when i do meditation
i keep reframing it according to
how well i'm meditating or you know it's
like this is a very common problem for
anybody trying to get
gets into meditation if that makes you
feel better um
and so but what i found is that uh
every i have to because i'm forced to
because of my back i have to
every single morning i have to get up
and now i go down two because we've kind
of redone the garage area and it's kind
of like a gym and i've got like a yoga
mat down there
i play some like peaceful music some
like spotify platelet meditation
playlist
you know i've got so many and i know i
keep promising putting this on the
siding i will
someday but my
stretching sort of yoga sort of back
essential routine every single day is
about 20 minutes every single day
and so and i'm not thinking about
anything at that point
other than what i'm doing to my body you
know what i'm saying
yeah i'm do stretching in this way i'm
stretching in this way i'm doing this
move i'm doing that move and i'm playing
this music or whatever so i think that's
kind of become my meditation time
yeah and i and and i have to do that in
order to stay healthy but i also have to
do that in order to then work out
without hurting myself
so it ends up being about an hour and a
half total time
every day every day pretty much of doing
the you know half
20 minutes or so of the stretching and
then like a workout that's about an hour
long
i think that that's become
pretty essential and it's become so so
much of a rhythm in quarantine
that i'm kind of nervous about life
going back to the way that it was i mean
a lot of people have been talking about
this lately they're like oh now that
life seems like it's about to return to
normal and you know
everybody's gonna be vaccinated and
we're gonna start doing all the things
that we were doing before
there's this anxiety that a lot of
people are having about some people it's
like social anxiety like i haven't been
in a crowd i'm kind of nervous about
that
i don't that's not me that's not how i
think about it i think i have an anxiety
about
being pulled out of
these rhythms that i've been able to
establish
that like yeah i can okay if we go to
new york city i can do the back routine
on the hotel floor right but if you want
to work out you're like well i'm going
to go to the hotel gym
and what are they going to have and well
what am i going to do at night i can't
go i can't
i can't go get my sauna you know what
i'm saying it's like these are
privileged
problems but i but i just have this
anxiety about
not this has become such a part of
my existence at this point i haven't
thought about it in these terms
in this non-time but i think it's
probably one of the reasons that i
feel good right now and feel kind of
healthy because i've got these things
that i'm doing almost
every single day that are pretty
consistent and not focused on
doing doing doing doing doing i think
that's why now is a good time to have
this conversation because as things
start to change it's like okay is there
is there something new to incorporate or
something that has
that you started to incorporate that you
want that
that there's a new priority associated
with it that you're going to protect
that
you know um
i hope that's true of me that i'll
i'll i'll keep getting up and
and taking that time well i mean the the
good news
for me is the fact that i have like if i
don't
do the stretching i literally
can't go on about my day like i will
i'll be in pain for the rest of the day
so
that's kind of the blessing of a bat of
a lower back injury
or chronic pain or whatever it is is
that
okay like if we're we're traveling and
we're like okay we got to be at this
interview at seven o'clock or something
like that i'm like okay well i've got to
get up
i've got to have at least 20 minutes to
sit there and do these stretches and you
can't go faster than the stretches allow
and so
i guess that's a good thing sometimes
there's you know pain can be
an inconvenience can be a blessing if
you turn it into something that
ends up being sort of meditative
hashtag hair biscuits let us know uh if
any of that resonates with you
uh you got a wreck for us i do um sure
this is gonna be in the category of
things that are uh
old or at least not current
that most of you probably didn't watch
when it was around
and so maybe like me and you uh
you can discover it for the first time
the hbo
show the watchman based on the
graphic novel which was probably the
only graphic novel i've ever read and i
really liked it
um this is i mean it's been like four
years or so that this
three years i don't think it's that old
of course we've been in la for 10 years
i wouldn't believe that either
but hold on there's only is it there
there was only there was only one season
it was like a limited series right
or is it is there going to be a second
season i haven't heard about a second
season no
okay well maybe it's not as old as i
thought it was and maybe there is
going to be a second season but anyway
uh
excellent television show and
the same thing that happened to me
happened to you when you were watching
it which is
halfway through the season you begin to
think
i is this it started really good and
then halfway through the season you're
kind of like is this getting to be
too complex how are they going to bring
this all together and i don't like super
complex shows and so i'll end up i
started to
almost kind of lose interest and then
the way it all came together in the last
two episodes was just
yeah some of the best television that
i've ever seen i would say that
the penultimate episode is one of my
favorite episodes of a
show it's the first episode of a show
that i've watched and then i sat down
the next night and i watched that same
episode again before
even though i could go to the finale in
the way that it weaves
and that and that redeemed the whole
thing for me because well that i thought
the season as a whole i'm like it's
really good but that was a that was just
mind-blowing the second and last episode
was so good
that i thought that the sh the season
was over and i told jesse i was like
that was incredible she was like what
what about that story line and that
story line and that storyline isn't
they're going to be oh
i was like oh yeah there's probably oh
yeah there is another episode but the
way that they kind of explore these
science fiction concepts in a fresh way
but then also weave in
the issues of racial justice in a way
that
doesn't feel reaching or
forced you know a lot of times people
might be like well i'm going to do this
thing and it's going to have
this social justice issue in it
yeah and i'm going to do it in a way
that feels preachy or whatever
they do it in a way that is very
compelling and very relevant to the
story
and very effective and just makes it
that much better of a story
so the watchmen on hbo hbo just i mean
they've been a sponsor before
they do so many things right like hbo
man just do it right
all right y'all we'll keep talking every
day
is just another day of your life thanks
for making us a part of that's true
some of those and once a week let us be
a part of your life
well on this show and there's another
show pretty much every day you know
there's a lot of stuff a lot of content
just take over your life
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]